[Music]
ted has been navigating this high heat
also looking at the air quality from
some of that heat also from california
here he is all right thanks brian
outside right now we got the haze right
it has returned to the region we knew
that was going to happen and warned you
about it yesterday but of course the
excessive heat continues and that's the
reason why the heat warning has been
extended now for another day through
tomorrow 9 p.m 107 at this hour our
record today was 110 degrees did not
reach that thankfully humidity is also
snuck up to 10 we'll see it go up a
little more for tomorrow too currently
outside 108 for centennial hills 102
summerlin 104 for the lakes 108 for
downtown 107 for green valley we should
be at 98 this time of the year look at
these numbers here 104 for roads ranch
mountains edge 108 for you in henderson
outside the valley even hotter on death
valley of course at 117 one way for
laughlin and 106 currently for you
joining us from boulder city the reason
for the heat of course high pressure we
talked about this this clockwise flow
the sinking air is what keeps us hot
still around the region but a little bit
more northeast now when you can see its
flow and that's bringing these some
isolated storms right now into arizona
very isolated very few but we're
tracking these because tomorrow will
increase some of that moisture for
tomorrow low-grade monsoon moisture
nothing big but chances will increase a
little for tomorrow in fact everything
will be isolated most of the impacts
will really be east of us here in mohawk
county but can't rule out a chance of
isolated cells that will come off the
mountains and that goes for also the
evening hours for tomorrow and also
friday too this could be our last gasp
of the monsoon because we're starting to
wrap up monsoon season which simply
happens in mid september smoke forecast
does show that smoke that hayes over us
right now will start to move its way to
the north that southeasterly flow pushes
that to the north so the skies will
clear a little for tomorrow and into
your friday too it won't be as hazy as
what we've seen these past few days
tonight 84 degrees overnight extra warm
will break another
record warm low
106 for tomorrow hot and partly sunny
isolated thunderstorms are a slight
possibility but mainly in the mountains
your record 110 tomorrow don't think
we'll reach that but we'll come close
highs a neighborhood by neighborhood
under four for centennial hills along
with mountains edge 105 north las vegas
104 for you and henderson will be at 103
for prep and 104 for boulder city
tomorrow afternoon for your thursday
here's your eight on the eight forecast
so after tomorrow look at this these
numbers start to drop thankfully but
we'll still be riding about five to
seven degrees above normal but we'll dry
out as the monsoon retreats back to the
south that's your most accurate forecast
denise odi